i got a theory hypothesis
i don't know what it is about aaron
rodgers i i look we're we're
two weeks and a few days away from
finding out whether he shows up or
doesn't show up for training camp and
the reason we're talking about it is
he's had every opportunity to let us
know whether or not he's going to be
there
and he has chosen not to tell us we'll
see
so until we find out it's
it's free and fair and proper
to play out the various scenarios i
think he's going to show up
i think that mark murphy the ceo of the
packers wants him to not show up
i think murphy would prefer number one
rogers becomes the clear villain in all
of this by not showing up hey you're
under contract got here under your
contract on your contract you're under
contract for three more years contract
contract contract
you're in the wrong for not showing up
you signed this contract
you committed to this team you need to
be here that's
what the attitude likely will be if
history is a guide
the team's fans always line up behind
the laundry and in green bay
the key distinction is the fans also own
the team so they're even more inclined
when push comes to shove between
franchise and player
they're going to side with the franchise
and if player violates his contract and
stays away
player becomes the one with whom they're
the most upset which makes them less
inclined to be upset
with mark murphy or brian gudekunst on
top of that
they get to find out what jordan love
has the expectations plummet
for 2020 and after the year
the packers not having to worry about
rogers playing for another team
and maybe winning a super bowl and
making them look stupid
for moving him to another team or
setting the stage for him to want out by
drafting jordan love
you don't have to worry about that this
year you trade him after the season
and i still think that the packers get
more trading rogers
after 2021 then they would get trading
him now because you're gonna have more
teams who have gone through a full
season
who have decided this quarterback that
we believed in we no longer believe in
let's get in the running for aaron
rodgers there will be more teams at the
table
if they decide right now to trade him
it's the broncos and who
who maybe the raiders maybe
and i think from the raiders perspective
they'd have to consider it because
we don't want them to go to the broncos
so i
i i think that the best way for rogers
to get out
may be to show up this is where i was
heading with all that
i think that even though the packers
have shown no inclination to trade aaron
rodgers
think if he shows up and
murphy and gouda koontz then the board
of directors and the executive committee
all realized
this is going to be a very awkward and
stressful season everyone is just coming
off of what was
a very awkward and stressful 2020
because of the pandemic because think
about it even though they got all the
games in
i was talking to somebody about this
yesterday there was a constant sense
of holding your breath while waiting for
the bottom to fall out of the season
every week when's it going to happen
when's it going to happen who's going to
be the team that can't play a game when
are they going to have to cancel games
where are they going to play the games
they canceled when are they going to
play the games they canceled what
happens if they don't play all the games
are they going to determine playoff
spots based on win percentage remember
that was a
big topic last year i don't think the
packers want another year
where they're worried about something
every week and this year
instead of worrying about the pandemic
they're worrying about what aaron
rodgers is going to say or do
that will will cause a mini brush fire
that they need to worry about we know
he's got a propensity to make passive
aggressive comments and we know that
he goes as i know we've seen it we play
the clip all the time
of him calling me out by name during the
i think it was 2016 or 2017 season when
i was connecting the dots to show that
he was making passive aggressive
comments about then coach mike mccarthy
oh
and he was you could see the devil on
one shoulder and the angel on the other
coaxing him the devil was coaxing him to
call me out
the angel said don't give that guy the
benefit don't give him the power
by letting him know that you're reading
what he's writing
and you want people to not waste their
time reading that crap
yeah you know i may put that on my
tombstone i don't know
don't waste your time reading this crap
but
i don't think the packers want a full
season of
needing an interpreter to figure out
what it is that aaron rodgers was saying
in his post-game press conference or in
his midweek press conference mandatory
press availabilities that he has so to
finally land this plane
so that you're not wasting your time
listening to this crap
i think if he shows up there's a chance
the packers decide to trade him there's
a chance that they give the broncos a
call
there's a chance that come week one
it'll be jordan love versus either
jameis winston or taysom hill
and aaron rodgers will be starting for
the denver broncos
there's a chance that happens if he
shows up
so aaron to get out
you may have to get in you may have to
show
up because i think when you show up
and maybe hey look maybe this is super
genius
evil genius aaron rodgers realizing
how to manipulate the situation he's
created enough chaos
in the offseason to make mark murphy
not want him there so easiest solution
he doesn't show up
great he shows up oh boy
now we got to deal with him all year
let's just go ahead and trade him
and be done with it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports